Solloway at their own mess. That's Latin for hello world.
This is Jessica from comp Trump. We're borrowing her right now.
She's off wondering if AI is breeding humans,
the code behind matchmaking apps and other fun stuff,
but native Lang and comp job are teaming up and heading to youtube to film a
short series about the amazing ways code and language overlap and get mixed
together. The history of computer translation,
like passwords aren't real words anymore. She has some cool things to show us.
We're also giving her a chance to share a personal note about being a female
programmer,
so please enjoy these extra linguistic insights from our visiting coder before
we get back to our regular programming.
It'll be hard work and I'm grateful to have her here.
We hope you'll catch the videos,
particularly if you're a fan of computational linguistics or programming
languages. See you in just a couple of Fridays. Until then,
stay tuned and subscribe for language.